people like JK Rawling need to stop
because my people are dying because of
her I was sent this video this morning
this is a radical trans activist in the
UK celebrating the death of JK Rowling
and I saw it so now you have to see it
here we go and people like JK Rawling
need to stop because my people
are dying because of her she killing us
oh thing about this book jking
she wrot book yeah wrote a book to kill
off the queen of the turfs and it is
glorious I only wish that scene could
have been even more brutal the queen of
the turfs that sounds like a title for a
book that's a book that so Turf what
what does Turf stand for again trans
exclusive trans exclusionary radical
trans exclusionary radical feminist uh
this is known as a woman basically right
so she's the queen of the turf she's the
queen of the people who hates trans
people by the way she's repeatedly said
she doesn't hate trans people it's the
same this is what I mean when Rogan does
the soft glove thing or when I try to
qualify it with you know live with
dignity and all this stuff they don't
want to give you an inch these people
it's it's very sad you know in this
weird way we can mock these
purple-haired weirdos and all that stuff
and and to some extent we should because
we have to expose it but in another way
you should have sympathy for these
people because they have they have been
so bludgeoned by an ideology that was
fueled through activism and through
algorithms and tumbler or God knows what
that they end up like like you should be
sympathetic in a weird way to that
person it's just absolutely insane I am
not going to buy that book in case it's
clear I am in case it's not clear I am
not going to buy that
book